and here are some other famous faces
you'll see at the big game many are in
some big money Superbowl commercial back
street may already be on next year's
halftime show meanwhile Wilson I'm a
close talker who's got his own ad has
his sights set on Legally Blonde three I
can't imagine anything that would be
more fun Reese played such a great
character
yeah I've not loved do Legally Blonde
three Sarah Michelle Gellar's Olay ad
pays tribute to her past screen Queen
roles but does she remember her very
first commercial when she was five and a
brunette
I got King I don't remember what I had
for breakfast yesterday let alone what I
was doing in 1981 I also caught up with
Real Housewives of Atlanta star NeNe
Leakes who told me all about Andy
Cohen's recent baby shower it was
amazing maybe we won baby game we did
that's why y'all were on the tables I
couldn't figure it out I was like they
drank that and Jenny McCarthy who's here
with her Sirius XM radio show gave me
hints about her other hit series the
masked singer now who do you think the
bumblebee is by the way don't get too
caught off of that cuz a lot of people
think they know there's some leaks
online and I'm sorry you're wrong
[Music]